liam welcome to not our podcast but our
first one-piece discussion ever maybe
except uh the one report i guess
[Laughter]
yeah well uh thank you yeah welcome to
the uh the liam and manu podcast which
is uh different from our usual one
because we have funky backgrounds we're
just confusing people with um
talking about one piece building large
channels on one piece then starting a
podcast about something completely
different and then bringing it all the
way back to one piece everything always
comes back to one piece that's that's
what we should know by now
well let me ask you right from the start
for retention purposes
you should know that
what are your thoughts on the last
chapter what's gonna happen and what did
happen okay there's a lot of questions
there um
holy crap
it's not as if i have a whole channel
dedicated to like dissecting all of
those questions in great detail
my feelings on the last chapter
that was all right that's pretty good
well i think just yeah just one of yeah
oda can do better
just um
casually throws us what uh in retrospect
because i'm still kind of shell-shocked
about
the whole thing
but in retrospect i think this is
probably the biggest bombshell that we
have ever had in one piece
would i be wrong cause i can't think of
a bigger one i don't think i don't think
you would be wrong just because of the
fact how
this chapter not only affects the future
of the story as many other bombshells
have had in the past but it also like
goes back and like in reverse will
change a lot of things about the story
as well it retrospectively
changes the last quarter of a century so
i guess the one million
very question which is not a lot of
berries but like let's go let's go with
the 1 billion
it's like that's a lot of money um what
do you think okay because like i feel
like there there's like kind of like
three fractions or like three options
out there for like what happened to
luffy which is what is literally on
everyone's mind do you think it's a
that this is simply
something joy by related devil fruit
doesn't play a role is it b
and joy boy kind of thing or is it c
joy boy and a different devil fruit that
we just didn't know about until now uh
it's got to be c at the moment i i i
shouldn't say it's going to be c that's
that's uh too imperative um
my belief is c uh
i think there have been far too many
i wouldn't even say hints but like
outright jabs at this stage that the
gomu gomonumi is not what it seems and
it is in fact a different devil for it
altogether
and it's hard to deny that joy boy is
involved in all of this maybe
coincidentally probably not
so at the moment
as well yeah my money is definitely on c
and i'm favoring the resin idea at this
stage i i think it's so for those of you
who don't know the reason idea is
basically that luffy's power isn't
rubber per se but basically an upgraded
version of it i guess would be fair to
say no
where basically raisin has a lot of the
properties in different states that
rubber has but it also has additional
features which for example have to do
with heat
it's a heat resistant it's still
an insulator for electricity which would
explain the anal thing well when you say
heat resistant it actually uh melts when
heat is applied yeah it's melted it
becomes valuable
yeah
exactly so it would
be a logia fruit right in that sense i
guess
maybe or a katakuri style fruit where he
can just
paramecia manipulate his body
weirdly right and i think if i remember
correctly so i maybe i don't know i
think you planning to do a video on this
and i'm i've definitely been thinking
about it actually honestly just didn't
do one because i thought you already did
one which
so we'll see we'll see maybe we have two
videos on it but yeah like um it's like
in case you don't know i think the
person who originally came up with that
idea is you don't as far as i know at
least because i've seen that idea
interesting yeah
i don't follow uteron because i don't
speak japanese i saw the idea on reddit
from a user named pringles
i feel like it has been on this channel
a while ago so but i'm not sure if he's
like the original original person or if
he's just
it is his thing it is very trademark
uteron because it does incorporate the
uh the gorowasa of uh 1043.
it does indeed so that might be the
original source so yeah
um and usually i hate that sort of thing
but i i'm kind of on board with it
because of the gigantic pile of evidence
that comes from elsewhere in this case
exactly i mean i've really kind of
shifted my mind a little bit because i
was i used to be a person especially
before that big used to be a person you
did it on the first time
yeah oh i didn't know that
carry on
anyways
anyways
so i i used to be a human being that um
i was not very fond of the entire guru
was the thing so like the workplace and
so far and like oh yeah of course like
oda is playing like hiding things in the
cover stories and everything i was
really against that i thought that was
kind of like you're trying a bit too
hard which is funnily enough now
something people keep telling me all the
time so the tides have truly turned out
you've become the thing you wanted most
yes indeed as you usually do as you
usually do but yeah i think there has
been a lot of like instances where that
has actually been confirmed more or less
that like certain chapters just contain
the word place and like a lot of things
have been hinted at in cover spreads
before like kaido and momo and so on and
so forth
so it's something i've been
because i've been becoming much more
open to in general which is why the
raisin idea
in combination like not only with the
workplace but also like other factors in
general just because it would make sense
with luffy's power until now
is like probably the
or one of the top contenders at the
moment
one thing that i
and that's just a personal opinion i'd
like to know what you think about it one
thing that
bugs me a little bit about it as much as
i like the idea and as cool as i think
it is
is i feel like if luffy's devil fruit
has actually not been the gomu gomi all
along i would personally want it to be a
bit more different
than just be a slightly upgraded version
of rubber if that makes sense so what's
your thought on that yeah i get what you
mean and i have written my video on this
and it gets into a really contentious
topic because
rubber depending on who you talk to is
technically already resin because it's
the resin of a rubber tree which um
excretes in the form of latex which is
rubber and just like that
it's a contentious point amongst the
scientific or the pseudo-scientific
online community
oh yeah i try to work in at least one
excrete in every video
i have my list there
keep going i i get what you mean though
you would expect and this is why i think
people jump to all of the like the sun
wukong or the mythical zoo and
conclusions that if luffy's devil fruit
isn't like ah i'm a basic rubber man
then it's some sort of special i'm a god
fruit and resin isn't
you know it's it's not this
i would say
it's not the sexiest of answers for the
big
revelation to be oh luffy's actually a
technical rubber of some other kind see
it's really interesting because i would
like i would have liked to say it would
be the oldest of answers to this mystery
because it would be a very very odor
thing to do to go into that direction
kind of be like it was not the gomu
going on me after all it was the raisin
raisin on me i'm like okay well that's
slightly different
but then at the same time like what i
personally felt in the chapter like i
kind of got quote unquote non one piece
vibes in a good way it was very shoneny
in the sense that like you have like
this awakening that luffy has and like
that it's it's something oda has never
done really before
we're like i i would argue there have
been has been a lot of foreshadowing
already
like especially in onegashima but also
before about like the joy boy connection
and all and so that's not the issue but
like
that basically luffy gets a power
upgrade that is not him working hard or
tries to like you know with katakuri
like fighting hard or you know
developing a new technique which has
usually been how it's been going yeah so
that has been very un-oda-like
at least that first impression of it
what's your take on that i
agree with you
i will say that the thing that
and without this
i don't like the resin idea at all
without this one thing this one weird
trick i'm about to
reveal gonna make it all work the thing
that really gets to me is um that
interview oda did and i think it was
september 2020 where he revealed his top
three favorite scenes in the series have
you gone back and looked at those sets
with the saba audi one right yes there's
a very weird number two favorite scene
which involves quite specifically a uh a
talking starfish discussing resin and
explaining how the
bubbles work
and that
is such a weird thing that of all of the
one piece that is the scene that he's
you know second most proud of or holds
is his second favorite i guess
especially if you do look at the his
favorite scene which is the party on
skypea which was clearly now in
retrospect the
look look like this is gonna be sun god
nico you just don't know it yet kind of
you know things so yeah that gives that
third favorite scene which is the
opening of one
and if you look at all of them i'm i'm
not usually this person because this is
this sounds very tinfoil conspiracy but
if you look at all of them it sounds
like what oda was doing there was a bit
of a message
no luffy is the sun god
his powers are resin and we'll find out
on wanna sort of thing yeah
it's gotten to the point where i don't
know if those are actually his favorite
scenes or if he was just trolling us
and giving us some foreshadowing
i mean either would be fun when it comes
to one piece
i
how do i even explain this um
i believe in oda's ability to make
really weird and wacky and simple ideas
into that escalation
i don't think
he necessarily or even often ever relies
on those sorts of big transformative
sorts of ideas
and so
with the whole sun wukong thing and
every idea that relates to it
i really like it right i'm really yeah
i'm really curious in general because
for example one assumption that is
incredibly incredibly legitimate by the
way
is that luffy is melting or like
liquefying in some way or four based on
that one panel we got
which i think is again a fair assumption
because we have the sabbah
scene that people have dug out we have
you know the raising connection to
rubber and so on and so forth
but we still like it might as well be
like fur or something like it doesn't
have to necessarily be him melting it
could really be like hair or whatever
really like
a lot of people have also said that it's
just the straw hat as well it's not
actually luffy it's just like a third
party they're
this is like um one of my favorite
thoughts just because i love crack
theories but there's even a thought
right now that it's caribou
on him
instead of actually
which would be the ultimate troll yes
i do feel that would be a very risky
movement
people would be so mad
people would be furious and it would be
amazing i mean even still i think like
even if if it's something else like i
feel like that luffy is joy but has
awakened joy boy is pretty much
confirmed because we know it's not
momonosuke he kind of communicates that
with zunisha
and it seems like i've mentioned that in
in my reaction to the chapter
but there is the sound effect in the
story that was not translated properly i
felt like it's like this heartbeat sound
effect where luffy's heart apparently is
supposed to like start beating again
yeah and so i think what was interesting
what it was it was like yeah it's like i
think
like it's a really are we talking about
the drums or are we talking about that
panel in the close-up no i mean the
panel where luffy is like with the black
eyes and close-up
uh
no that's a
bump
in english yeah exactly so that is
basically in in japanese it's pretty
clearly like a heartbeat sound
like hearts that like starts beating
again and so i personally thought it was
implied that you know luffy's presence
the people who were familiar with luffy
it's kind of this mirrored concept the
people who are familiar with luffy feel
his presence vanished so that's kaido
it's momo it's zorro you know like the
people who like uh have like good enough
hockey to feel luffy's where law i think
was also one of them
you know who feel luffy's presence
vanish and then in return you have
zunisha recognize
the presence of someone she or he knows
by joy boy reappearing in the moment
where luffy's heart starts beating again
which is why i actually and this is
where i'm really curious what your
thoughts are where i personally at the
moment actually tend towards the idea
that luffy has actually been possessed
in a way
by joyboy
which at least the chapter in that you
know narrate like narrative like
structuring seems to suggest at least at
the moment that luffy's spirit has died
or vanished and now joy boy has taken
over which is why zunisha kind of
recognizes that so what
do you would you agree with that reading
i have of the chapter and if so or if
not so like what what are your thoughts
if that were actually the case i agree
with that's what oda is trying to leave
you with that that's the cliffhanger it
looks like luffy is gone or gone for now
and something else
oh well obviously joy boy has inhabited
him
what makes me skeptical
is again that this is one piece and
oda's cliffhangers they often
they're often red herring treacherous
they're often meant to make us believe
one thing that we then talk about for a
week or two and then the chapter comes
out it's like oh it was actually this
other thing like he did with the whole
um absolutely true the whole devil fruit
thing with zunisha how the way he
structured the panels was implying that
the five elders were talking about
zunosha when that's yeah 99 percent not
the case anymore oh yeah i'm pretty sure
yeah
it threw us for a nice loop
absolutely i think i think the yeah i
would argue that that has been kind of
resolved with them actually directly
instructing cp zero to assassinate luffy
basically yeah yeah so i think that
would be weird i don't
know how much i i like the possession
camp
just because it might seem a bit too
obvious what i enjoy more
is the idea that it's like a shirahoshi
poseidon situation where
a power or a legacy or a will has
awakened within this person
right but not necessarily like a full-on
personality i guess is there is there
anything before because i do have a
like
really important question about that of
course as well but like before that is
there anything else about the chapter
that you would like to share or that you
like any thoughts you feel like you want
to put out there uh
mad respect to uh bob lucci of cp zero
for just taking that death like a boss
that is uh due to the end of chap due to
the end of the chapter i think that's a
very under appreciated moment and
just wanted to give this time to show
that it's interesting yeah i would agree
and one thing i found interesting
because i was thinking like why people
and white was so easy to jump on that
and i think the fact was that
he showed
for a zp0 agent he showed a lot of
humanity in like the few lines he got he
was like i envy you drake for like the
path you chose he was like i really
don't want to do this
[Music]
like it was you you want me to interrupt
kaido's [ __ ] yeah i think i think rob
lucci was a great villain like don't get
me wrong like this like cold kind of
like forced into this
kind of like numb
villainous role was really interesting
like he made a great villain for ana's
lobby but i think what made this guy so
much more relatable why people were like
respect was that he was very genuinely
human in his reactions to everything
like most relatable almost
in like you know an anime you always
have like oh yeah i'm definitely gonna
diet he was like
i can't
go up there
between those two so and then like he
was like then he did it anyway and even
though it's you know it doesn't serve
out interest there's like a certain
level of respect to interrupting the
fight of you know the strongest thing in
the world and knowing that it's probably
going to be your final moment absolutely
and so i absolutely agree that was a
great
i love it when oda manages to
characterize characters in like
very short time spans i think he did
that wonderfully with yamato like even
after five chapters of knowing her it
was already she was already really well
characterized and now it almost feels
like she's been there like since forever
basically and so like that's another
example i think of a character that got
characterization such a short time span
but made his last moment in his short
while on screen really worthwhile yeah i
would say hats off but um that's very
much on to uh to bob lucci that's very
much on and then one more question that
just popped randomly into my head
because i think a lot of people have
been kind of avoiding the fact whether
kaido can still awaken his fruit because
in an awakened zone state or not
and i was always like it was kind of
looking like luffy was gonna go in a
direction where there was kind of you
know
they were head to head and like it could
go either way
and now luffy has been defeated but is
gonna come back stronger clearly is kind
of the show like the shonani
thing that is being hinted at obviously
at least and so i feel like now it would
seem a lot more reasonable if zoro if
kaido actually had another ace up his
sleeve as well you know what i mean
if zero awakened his devil fruit that
that would be amazing
that would be a good video
[Laughter]
i guess i'm not sure in in my
mind brain of head canon the awakening
of kaido's devil fruit was the ability
to turn into the dragon in the first
place
in the first place kind of go from the
fish to them yeah but again that that
hasn't even come close to being
explained even if there is a fish
involved it could just be you eat it and
then straight up a dragon
it would be it's kind of what is implied
with momo right
yeah yeah exactly if they have the same
but maybe that's why vegapunk's devil
fruit was a failure because it skipped
the fish form
who knows things questions so many
questions
oh this devil fruit is an absolute
failure it just goes to the strong part
right away i wanted the magikarp not the
gyarados put the fruit in the bin went
down with it
literally
i would find it a bit
strange if someone of kaido's prominence
had not awakened his devil fruit
but that's the same sort of feeling i
get with whitebeard because he's not a
confirmed awakened devil fruit user
right then i feel like with whitebeard
you could probably make the excuse that
if whitebeard had used his awakened
devil fruit at marine for it he already
did a lot of collateral damage in
general as it was the the problem with
kaido's fruit is that it's a mythical
zoan and we don't
really understand how they function
because they're all quite unique
so it would be easy to say that he
wasn't awakened because he doesn't
follow the standard zone you know big
bulky zombie transformation
yeah it's
yeah it's really interesting i hope that
kaido still has something up his sleeve
because now right now i would say he's
pretty like there's probably no one on
the island right now who could finish
finish him off but he's definitely
vulnerable right now if luffy gets the
power up that we all hope he gets i
guess now based on all this
um
kaido would definitely also have to be
able to put up a fight still i feel it's
interesting because i'm trying to think
back on luffy fights right now and if
his opponents usually have that kind of
uh upper state once he's had his you
know his final power up and generally
not really they just kind of remain as
they are
if i'm recalling things correctly
like with katakuri he didn't have a
special thing after snake man for
example that is true but then again
kaido also is a more special villain in
the fact that he's the
big baddie of the entire fight right and
luffy is again what we discussed earlier
not
just i mean he did grow stronger during
the he did the katakuri move with the
conquest hockey thing right which is
like the focus was kind of on
observation uh what was it on on
armament hockey first uh you know after
the third the first defeat right at the
beginning of the arc and then it kind of
shifted to
armament haki in preparation for the
raid that wasn't enough then he found
out congress haki you can use that to
fight as well so i feel like that was
kind of the in-fight power-up in
quote-unquote or like the thing luffy
learned and like copied from kaido but
now i feel like since it's it's
i think deo's ex machina is maybe a bit
too harsh because it has like this very
negative connotation but this kind of
you know it is like an external factor
that's now awakening in luffy or at
least so it seems
so i think it might be
fair to give kaido a sim or like another
sleeve
a card up another sleeve another card up
his sleeve another sleeve up his butt
that was about to say
wow okay they've got some interesting
designs
all right yeah let's let's stick all
sorts of stuff up carter's butt sure i
will say he he definitely has something
still remaining because throughout this
entire fight like it might not be
something huge but he keeps pulling out
new techniques or advanced versions of
old techniques so i definitely don't
think he's done yeah yeah he did
which i thought was hilarious he's like
you know and i and i still feel like we
need to see
yeah that moment where also
kaido kind of like
is really like dropping his like tension
and everything and you know embracing
and enjoying that fight
as well before the climax now one more
thing that i would like to know from you
is whatever this awakening is would you
agree with the fact that we are just
gonna seat like kind of like luffy at
marineford using congress hockey it's
gonna be something that's gonna burst
out of luffy he doesn't really know what
happens or can't really control it and
it's only something he will learn learn
about and control later when he maybe
meets shanks he will be told about it
you know with the devil fruit or when he
meets blackbeard it's something that he
will actually you know the closer you
get to to love tale that he's actually
going to learn have to learn about
embrace and then perfect
at a later stage in the story
so much of that depends on the nature of
the fruit itself um
i could see a situation where he's
awakened he has you know his new goopy
abilities and then he goes ah i once
fought a guy who did stuff like this let
me try out some of what he did
but
thinking about it
again like we mentioned this before you
always need somewhere to go and if luffy
has the advanced conquerors armament
observation and a double fruit awakening
just all done
what are we gonna do in that final saga
i don't know maybe something maybe
nothing go
naruto
like oh ancient weapon kind of whatever
but i do think also it would be more fun
to have like
have this be like an outburst kind of
thing and everyone's like holy hell
did he do that on purpose i know he
didn't do it on purpose but still kind
of like he probably won't master it you
know in the minute or so we've got
before nigoshima falls on the flower
capital i would say so as well like the
conquerors haki has a good excuse
because he was training with armament
and it was just you know same thing
different willpower
exactly it was very hockey focused and
now it's kind of moving more towards
that double fruit kind of
sphere i would say
well guys
thank you so much for coming leah make
sure to check him out in case you're for
some reason not subscribed to him he's
really working hard to become the first
one-piece creator to correct that one
million this year that's a strong way so
far so
go over check out his content he does
way more than i do um we also do have a
podcast together that i have not
officially shouted out on this channel
yet um which is going to be also in the
link in the description below well we do
not talk about one piece but just
general stuff with sophie
blue banana podcast and otherwise
that's it for my site watch another
video right here
cool
sorry i didn't know what to say at the
end though